you're doing a TED book yourself yes so
we we have a new cloud film called brain
power and we have been making it with
people from all over the world we're
just about to release it and I was
approached about seven months ago by the
TED Conference they're doing a new
they're called Ted books and they're
basically kind of like a TED talk but
it's a book it's 60 pages they're on the
iPad they have all these like videos and
music and enhanced and they're also for
the Kindle that's me do a book like what
if I take the script from this film I'm
just about to finish and show you all
the research or how I got to those lines
in the documentary so it's been really
fun so the the book really takes all of
our research from all the
neuroscientists and all the internet
research that we did around the film
brain power and we turned it into a 60
page book and you can link to clips of
the film and TED talks that relate to
research and neuroscience research and
so it really when you write a script
it's usually via culmination of a
culmination of so much work and it's
like kind of shows you how we got to all
this thinking so they're both being
released on November 8th and the film
will be released for free and we'll make
free customized versions for
organizations and then the Ted book will
be for sale
you